I once met a last so fine she was drunk
on barley wine I'd been to see for
months a three I knew I could make her
mine and the last was passed consent so
it was off with her we went
and rested her head and that's what
gentlemen do
[Music]
which disrespect barrio
[Music]
there once was a gala from Leeds who I
heard was good on her knees
so I docked my ship for an overnight
trip to take care of all my needs to
aspire to tales to tell a my best we got
the swelling down and performed
cunnilingus for an hour or so
[Applause]
[Music]
I once had a woman so fair whose womb
contained my air with a son by my side
the Seas we cried the child she would
bear but my girl she was no fool she was
working her way through school so I did
support when she chose to abort because
it's her body and therefore her choice
[Applause]
[Music]
the doctor said she would die so she
emptied her purse to lift the curse and
pray to stay alive she eloped the very
next day and in her grave she lay but
the scariest part of the story from the
start is I bet you assumed the doctor
was a man
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
there was a slot with texture yeah
[Music]
cuz it's Yoho but we don't say Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you